now New Zealand has declared a national
state of emergency as the country
continues to be battered by Cyclone
Gabrielle well Skies Nicole Johnston is
following the story from Sydney uh for
us hello to you Nicole now New Zealand
does not call these states of emergency
very often what's the situation
well the situation does appear to be
deteriorating some 225
000 people across the north island of
New Zealand are now without power only a
few hours ago that number was around 40
000. so officials are certainly
concerned as you said they don't
normally declare these states of
Emergency the last time was during the
covert pandemic and the Christ Church
earthquake so they're really worried
about Rising flood waters damaged
infrastructure roads Bridges footages
coming out of people waiting on their
rooftops to be rescued the military's
been called in 200 Personnel are trying
to help with it there is expected to be
a weakening of this ex-tropical Cyclone
on Wednesday as it starts to move from
the North Island to the South Island but
clearly New Zealand has a massive
cleanup operation ahead of it and this
is the second Mass flooding event
they've had in the last two weeks